en polonia en silesia del sur esta mina
lleva 120 años en funcionamiento y para
algunos es impensable que desaparezcan
las llenas deben tener un futuro esta es
la historia de esta región y la
principal fuente de empleos mi padre
trabajó en la mina tenía abuelo trabajó
en la mina y yo también
pero aquí las cosas parecen estar
cambiando estos jóvenes también proceden
de familias de mineros y sin embargo
hacen campaña contra la contaminación
causada por las minas
cuando nos instalamos el tejido de esos
pulmones era blanco como la nieve
y apenas una semana de respiraciones es
decir de bombeo de aire se volvieron
todos negros
las partículas de hollín están cubriendo
la ciudad es la razón por la que los
coches y las ventanas están sucias ahora
mismo están entrando en nuestros
camiones
el 20% del carbón que se consume en
polonia se utiliza como combustible
aquí el carbón es la principal fuente de
calefacción
ese olor solíamos llamarlo el olor del
invierno pero no es el olor del invierno
es el olor del hollín que sale de esas
chimeneas
nuestra sociedad está empezando a
entender que este es el camino correcto
para los problemas de salud y queremos
que eso carlos en todo el país está
surgiendo una mayor conciencia de los
problemas medioambientales y esto a
medida que aprenden sobre el humo y la
contaminación atmosférica algunos
también empiezan a fijarse en las
emisiones de co2 y su impacto en el
calentamiento global por su parte los
escépticos del clima nos recuerdan que
este invierno ha nevado bien como
siempre
pero para algunos la emergencia está en
otra parte
antiguo minero rafa scholarship siempre
se ha calentado con carbono
por supuesto una estufa gas sería mejor
pero no puedo costear un auto
especialmente desde que cambió de
trabajo trabajé en la mina durante dos
años y luego despidieron a 250 personas
hoy en día trabajo en la fábrica de
automóviles frías y apenas ganó la mitad
de lo que ganaba en la mina en silencia
no faltan puestos de trabajo pero para
el alcalde suplente de esta otra ciudad
minera los salarios son el principal
obstáculo para la transición energética
los mineros estarían encantados de dejar
de trabajar en la mina si pudieran
obtener los mismos salarios en otro
lugar pero hoy es difícil
[Música]
dinero un trabajo venerable en esta
histórica cuenca minera y un salario al
menos un tercio superior a la media
nacional
los sindicatos que durante mucho tiempo
se mostraron reacios al cambio acabaron
firmando el año pasado un plan para
cerrar todas las minas antes de 2.049
está previsto que ésta deje de funcionar
en 2030 mi padre era minero trabajaba en
esa mina se pensionó tras 25 años de
servicio y hoy es un feliz minero
retirado sabíamos que un día llegaría
ese momento crítico en el que el carbón
se volvería obsoleto y habría que
encontrar una ruta alternativa que era
un cubo
encontrar un camino alternativo esta es
la obra de eugenio es malinowski aquí
pone en marcha un programa regional se
instalan paneles solares en los tejados
de las viviendas financiado casi esta
totalidad por la unión europea a razón
de cuatro mil euros cada uno
este sistema ayuda a las personas a
pensar de otra manera si producen
electricidad también pueden calentarse y
observan
si logran pasar los cables por la
chimenea terminarán mañana por la mañana
si me dijeron que les pidiera permiso a
los deshollinadores para eso si es más
sencillo los otros 13 paneles solares
dicen que es suficiente para generar la
electricidad mensual que necesito
veamos si realmente funcionan las
energías renovables una fuente potencial
de empleo para su iglesia pero en ruda
slaska anatoli y sus trabajadores ya han
acaparado el mercado estos inmigrantes
ucranianos trabajan rápido y barato
y así hemos terminado ya está listo en
poco tiempo es conveniente y rentable
totalmente cubierto de paneles solares
este edificio de katawal la capital
regional forma parte de un parque
científico y tecnológico que crea nuevos
puestos de trabajo ecológicos de alta
tecnología y muy bien pagados
hacemos investigación probamos nuevos
materiales de construcción energías
renovables para potenciar su eficiencia
y por tanto su competitividad en el
mercado nacional y europeo
subimos al tejado para comprobar la
calidad del aire que ese día era muy
mala
esa niebla que se ve por todas partes es
la contaminación según patrick vial a
polonia haría bien en abandonar el
carbón lo antes posible otra van a
subsidiar las minas hasta 2049
es absurdo toda europa se ría de
nosotros porque ningún otro país ha
elegido en la fecha tan lejana para
deshacerse del carbón
pero con unas minas cada vez menos
rentables y una agenda política polaca
ocupada por la transición energética el
carbón podría desaparecer antes de lo
previsto